[Music]
I'm not just saying it when I say like I
really believe that I think you're just
one of the most prolific songwriters of
Our Generation and you're so underrated
I know you've been nominated 17 times I
know people know but like not enough I
think you're so gifted and your voice is
like quintessential like why I loved
country music growing up like that it's
perfect singer songwriter your tone
there's no one like it you know it's you
right when you start singing It's
amazing And congrat congratulations on
six nominations at the
gramys I have to I word vomit every time
I see you well it means so much coming
from you because you're so great oh
whatever you're nice you really are and
so to hear you say that is it means a
lot oh well the feeling is mutual I have
to ask this being one of the openly gay
people in country music that is that's
hard in that industry like and it I know
even for Shane who's our mutual friend
that you did shooked with that was hard
for him in the beginning like you know
because he was his own artist and it was
hard to get in the door now he's like
one of the best songwriters but like do
you feel supported in the industry I do
that's great yes I do and I even think
of a song like dear in security how far
how far things have come in that last
verse when I say she's really sure of me
yeah I never even thought of saying he
that's how far I feel like not only I've
come but the world has come that nobody
said oh maybe you should say he exactly
cuz previously people that we both know
in the country music industry that are
not openly gay like it's it's hard and
there people would tell them don't do
that it'll shut off a whole an entire
fan base it'll and it will kill your
career maybe maybe and I think it's
beautiful that you feel comfortable and
you didn't it wasn't even like a thought
you were like well this is me and I had
all those same concerns you know Shane
and I are around the same age and came
up in the same time but I just I knew
not being me would kill myself yeah my
soul and so you know you got to do yeah
I think it's such a great thing too for
other have you ever heard from other
artists that are younger than you I have
in fact I had a moment that really
touched me um Brookie and yeah she came
out and she got married and had this
beautiful wedding I think it was in
People magazine and I texted her to
congratulate her about being so
authentic and she said to me you being
you has made it easier for me to be me
and that really it hits me now the
greatest compliment ever you never think
that you're making a difference in that
way I mean you're just doing you yes
exactly and that really really clearly
I'm getting teary right now I know no I
am too I know I anytime I see someone
cry I'm like it's contagious I'm like oh
my God I'll cry with you um so then
congratulations shucked as incredible
and I I have literally been in the
process cuz I've heard from Shane like
the whole time too like it's evolved and
it's been like a decade in the planet oh
we've always had a dream of you being in
it oh my God he said it first I go I
cannot I cannot live in New York right
now like when I first started doing it
and I now I live in New York but yeah
yeah that's always been a dream of our
well just so you know I'm such a huge
fan of it it is so great the music is so
great I mean Tony Award nom that's
incredible did you ever think that would
happen in your career no to do that no
it was a bucket list for me to write a
musical but it was one of those things
that I always thought was way down the
road and so it came around at a
beautiful time because when Shane and I
jumped in we were both so naive to this
world we didn't know it was going to
take 10 years yeah so you know you start
looking at your life and you're like how
many more of these do I have in me so
I'm glad we started when we did because
we both loved it and um man there were
times I didn't think it was going to
open an envelope at different times much
open
Broadway it was a real it's been a real
Testament to persistence and he and
Robert horn who wrote the book and
myself our friendship we're like family
yeah well after 10 years it's a lot of
work hope you like them hanging out a
lot so this last album I think we can
both relate my last album is very
personal probably my most personal and
this is very personal for you and it's I
think the I love all your albums I'm
I've been such a fan but I do love that
you you like kind of broke the walls on
several of these songs and really let
people in I feel like you've kind of
always been that artist but it feels
like the next level do you feel like
that with this album I do and I and when
I was doing it I didn't even realize
that's what I was doing you know someone
at my label pointed out to me like this
is your most personal album and I said
really and he said yeah I mean a song
like dear insecurity like you are being
you're being vulnerable about yourself
not about a relationship with anyone but
yourself and I'm really proud hold
yourself accountable yeah I'm really
proud that you know that this album
ended up doing that I would have and
then like you said the production the
production's so vulnerable that it's
just you're naked well let's do another
um commercial break bry's latest multi-g
Grammy nominated album is called Brandy
Clark If you don't win one of those I'm
gonna protest um it's out now I'm like
nominated 17 times come on y'all she's
up for six of them I'm like go anyway we
will be I will be voting for
you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home